der januar war wieder ein monat des
gedenkens an den holocaust zwanzigster
januar die wannseekonferenz mit diesem
sensationellen remake das im fertigen
aufgeführt wurde dann der 27 januar
befreiung von auschwitz die politiker
die mit den schildern remember in der
hand sich vor dem bundestag haben
ablichten lassen das ist alles gut das
ist wichtig und trotzdem habe ich das
gefühl dass unser gedenken und zwar
immer mehr wirkt aber immer
wirkungsloser wird warum weil ich der
meinung sind dass in der gesellschaft
ein ganzer bereich von antisemitismus
irgendwie nicht ernsthaft eingeordnet
wird ich will ein paar beispiele geben
zum beispiel ist es in mode gekommen es
ist ja gut wenn man an die verbrechen
der kolonialzeit erinnert an die
deutschen verbrechen beispielsweise in
namibia den mord an den herero und nama
trotzdem habe ich das gefühl dass an
manchen stellen die kolonialen
verbrechen missbraucht werden um den
holocaust zu relativieren
und das ist nicht nur mein gefühl
sondern das deutet sich auch einfach an
dann haben wir eine überspitzte
israelkritik im land es gibt nur ein
einziges land auf der welt das das wort
israel kritik als begriff
aufgestellt hat das heißt nicht denn wir
haben nicht china kritik oder türkei
kritik obwohl es jeden grund gäbe diese
länder für ihre politischen zustände zu
kritisieren aber ausgerechnet
deutschland in dem sechs millionen juden
ermordet wurden leistet sich den luxus
israelkritik zum zu tanken zur weit
verbreiteten zu einer art massensport zu
machen zum teil geht das so weit dass
dem land sogar das existenzrecht
abgesprochen wird in minder reform wird
zu boykottmaßnahmen gegen israelische
waren aufgerufen das alles vor dem
hintergrund von auschwitz ist für mich
unfassbar und schließlich und endlich
haben wir einen ganzen bereich von
antisemitismus zum teil schweren
ausschreitungen von muslimischen bürgern
gegen juden in deutschland der von einem
teil der gesellschaft nicht thematisiert
der weg geblendet ausgeblendet wird da
wird weggeschaut und wer anspricht in
wird man vorher du bist ein rassist oder
islamophobie oder ich weiß nicht was und
das problem es währenddessen wir bei
rechter rechtsextremer hetze bei
antisemitismus aus dem rechten spektrum
beispielsweise hätte mit seinem denkmal
der schande ganz zu recht einen
proteststurm im ganzen land haben wird
über diese etwas wirren thesen
kolonialismus versus holocaust
israelkritik
wegschauen bei muslimischen
antisemitismus der wird auf akademischem
niveau diskutiert das halte ich für
wirklich völlig falsch das muss genauso
hart gebrandmarkt und ausgegrenzt werden
wie der rechte antisemitismus sie haben
das so treffend analysiert aber eine
frage hätte ich noch versuchen sie es
mal in aller kürze so zu sagen woran
liegt das dass ausgerechnet deutschland
dass er zumindest seit 20 jahren 30 ich
würde sagen geradezu professionell
gedenkt und auf das eigene der gedenken
ja auch sehr stolz ist warum kriegt
deutschland das nicht in den griff das
was sie gerade beschrieben haben was ist
da falsch gelaufen also zum einen fällt
auf dass das dass diese weniger
kritisierten
erscheinungsform von antisemitismus
immer aus der linken ecke kommen da ist
sicherlich ein problem da muss einfach
ein umdenken hin niemand der so was
kritisiert ist deswegen gleich rechts ja
das ist so ein spiel was gespielt wird
kritisierst du irgendwas dann wird mir
das vorgeworfen das begann schon im
historikerstreit als es um den ausbruch
des ersten weltkriegs ging da war die
paradoxe situation dass ein ehemaliger
es ammann hatte ein buch geschrieben in
dem er dem ersten weltkrieg schon
sozusagen das vorspiel zum zweiten
nannte und die deutsche kriegsschuld für
immer festgeschrieben hat und dann hatte
ein anderer der war im widerstand ein
historiker hat gesagt es ist aber so
schlimm barsten es waren eher alle und
dann warf der as a man
dem widerständler vor du bist ja nazi
und dieses spiel haben wir seit 50
jahren oder für oder 60 jahren und das
muss aufhören wir müssen antisemitismus
radikal und mit der wurzel ablehnen das
können wir uns in deutschland nicht
leisten ich will das für niemand anders
vorschreiben in der welt aber unser land
ist so belastet in seiner geschichte das
wir leise sein müssten das nicht wir die
sind die auf der straße stehen sowie in
bremen und sagen kauft nicht beim
israeli allein die assoziation die raubt
einem den atem wenn man weiß was damals
passiert ist und deswegen ich glaube da
ist ein problem ist wir müssen aufhören
es ist kein kavaliersdelikt es kann
jeder seine kritik äußern es kann auch
noch so wirre thesen über kolonialismus
geäußert werden das will ich überhaupt
niemand absprechen wir müssen das
genauso ablehnen und müssen den mut
haben und nicht plötzlich anfangen
akademisch zu diskutieren könnte es
nicht doch sein dass
dieses wirklich grauenvolle verbrechen
an den herero und nama ist eben doch so
sehr wie der holocaust und so weiter das
ist einfach unfassbar der holocaust ist
unvergleichlich
einzigartigen da gibt es nichts zu
deuten dran und ich glaube da ist eines
der probleme und das zweite ist auch
fiat auf ich glaube dass uns dieses
verständnis dieses verbrechens verfolgen
wird noch über generationen weil es so
unfassbar ist und ich glaube das ein
reflex der menschen ist das abzulehnen
das zu bagatellisieren das ist gar nicht
böse gemeint verständnis und das nicht
greifbare konkrete frage glauben sie
dass wir zu wenig über die täter
sprechen
also wir haben uns ja gerade diesen film
hätte ich auch sehr gelungen fand über
die wannsee-konferenz gesehen das war
ein reines gruselkabinett der täter
insofern hoffe ich schon dass die
erinnerung wachgehalten wird
andererseits gibt es immer wieder und
umfragen gerade jetzt eine das eben das
historische wissen an den schulen doch
eben sehr sehr gering ist und man kann
leider nicht davon ausgehen dass man
automatisch gewissermaßen mit der
muttermilch das wissen über diese
verantwortung und diese diese schuld
auch mitbekommt wenn man in einer
multikulturellen gesellschaft sind
müssen wir jeder generation dass weder
uns neu erarbeiten das eine ganz große
pädagogische herausforderung aber moment
mal wurde sich das denn überhaupt
erarbeitet wenn das wird es wird ist
wird so hoch trank immer darüber
gesprochen dass da etwas verloren gehen
können also ich habe an meiner schule
schon gehabt gut ich habe dann auch
geschichte studiert aber ich hatte auch
in meinem gymnasium war das schon ein
wichtiger punkt aber war das eben ist
das unter nicht dass eine der großen
ständen der nachricht das zu wenig
gesprochen wurde oder und wenn dann nur
zu abstrakt dass schon die generation
der kinder zu selten gefragt hat so
sollten zugehört hat das ist richtig und
das geht ja weiter im grunde genommen
müssten wir uns alle ehrlich machen das
heißt uns stehen die südafrikanischen
wahrheit' unten vielleicht sogar noch
bevor jede gemeinde jede familie wird
sich irgendwann mal ehrlich machen
müssen in hinblick auf die beteiligung
sie kennen diese untersuchung glaube 40
oder 30 prozent der deutschen glauben
und behaupten auch ihre angehörigen
hätten im in derzeit 33 45 widerstand
geleistet und es stimmt aber leider
nicht sind dann irgendwie 23 prozent ich
war ihr habt die genaue prozentzahl
nicht im kopf aber das zeigt schon wir
sind über du musst die sache anschauen
niemand ist schuld ich meine sie haben
mir das wort angesprochen mit der
israelkritik wo er fast gewissermaßen
deutschland einen trade mark drauf hat
schändlicher weise und es gibt ja diesen
diesen satz dem in seiner tiefe glaube
ich gar nicht genug im gar nicht tief
genug ermessen kann form vom
vorsitzenden des zentrale juden herrn
schuster in israel ist unsere
lebensversicherung und das ist nicht nur
einfach so dahin gesagt das ist ganz
konkret so gemeint unsere
lebensversicherung die brauchen wir wenn
es uns an den kragen gehen sollte und
deshalb verstehe ich auch nach wie vor
nicht dass deutschland teilweise bei
israelkritik mit macht seit es mit einem
ambivalenten abstimmungsverhalten bei
den vereinten nationen beispielsweise
dass man zu wenig auch das wort erhebt
wenn israel ein apartheidstaat genannt
wird also ich glaube man macht sich da
in einem vielleicht linken toleranz
begriff ist zu leicht wenn man sagt ja
es ist ja alles nur eine form des der
kritik die möglich sein muss dies leider
oft über das ziel hinaus israels unser
lebensversicherung ist ein ganz tiefer
setzen da ist gerade kürzlich was
passiert dass ich gerne ansprechen würde
und ich würde auch gern wissen was sie
davon halten frauen rwd und zwar hat vor
wenigen tagen vielleicht war es auch
erst gestern die berühmte amerikanische
schauspielerin whoopi goldberg die hat
in einer fernsehsendung plötzlich den
satz gesagt holocaust is not about race
im holocaust ging es gar nicht um die
rasse um rassismus sie hat gesagt da hat
verdi eine die tätergruppe war weiß und
die opfergruppe war weiß also die
deutschen und die juden da ging es nur
darum wie grausam der eine mensch zu zum
anderen sein kann das passt ja doch auch
irgendwo ident in die identitäts
debatten in dem man neu entscheidet wer
täter und wer opfer ist und was
rassismus ist und was nicht wie nehmen
sie diese identitätsdebatte in den usa
war ja das hat noch mal eine ganz andere
qualität als in deutschland wo goldberg
hat sich dafür entschuldigt sie hat das
falsch eingeordnet falsch verstanden da
spielen verschiedene kriterien mit rein
auch die das schwarz sein in amerika ist
ja auch ein sehr sensibles thema wie man
das angeht aber der antisemitismus ist
bei uns ja im moment gerade auch ein
großes thema der überwiegend von rechts
kommt und gerade wurde auch jetzt wir
fangen die rechte an sie wollen bücher
verbieten in denen der holocaust
geschildert wird weil das die gefühle
der kinder also und auch der versklavung
zum beispiel also alles was die weiße
geschichte irgendwie was die weißen
schlecht dastehen lassen könnte also da
spielt vieles ineinander mit rein an
vielen verschiedenen ecken ich was ich
mitbekommen haben dass die abgeordnete
marie taylor green gesagt hat dass die
feuer in kalifornien sein verursacht
worden von
jüdischen finanziers die mit space
lesern das angefacht hätten also wieder
ist nichts abstrus und abenteuerlich
genug in florida wurden gerade und sechs
anderen staaten wie sagt man zettel
verteilt wo gesagt wurde wo die schuld
für den corona pandemie den juden in die
schuhe geschoben wurde und donald trump
hat ist auch ein bisschen salonfähig
gemacht dass die rechten auf die straße
gehen das war auch vergangene woche in
florida ich habe es noch nicht gewusst
ob mein social media sind videos wenn
man das sieht was sie sagen mittlerweile
offen und auf plakaten tragen das ist
kann man kaum also es wirklich schwer zu
fassen nur vorsichtig zwei deutsche
zeitungen haben behauptet während der
korona epidemie israel hätte nur die
eigenen jüdischen bürger geimpft und den
palästinensern dass die den impfstoff
vorenthalten nur eine der beiden
zeitungen hatte die eier diese
falschmeldung zurück zu nehmen das ist
nicht wahr möchte ich dich nehmen dann
also man kann ja schon einmal über diese
dokumentation sprechen die es im
öffentlich-rechtlichen gab von format
steuerung f so hieß das da ging es genau
darum dass die israelis ihre leute also
die juden vermeintlich impfen und die
palästinenser sozusagen vom impfstoff
fernhalten auch das was natürlich ein
klassisches
antisemitisches motiv was da verbreitet
wurde obwohl erstens in israel 20
prozent der menschen nicht juden sind
und selbstverständlich genauso geimpft
wurden und zweitens als israel angeboten
hat der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde impfstoff zu liefern
haben die palästinenser das abgelehnt
war der spiegel und die frankfurter
rundschau und die frankfurter rundschau
hat den mut gehabt dass mindestens
zurückzunehmen der spiegel hat es nicht
so dass der kollege henning voigt das
gemacht haben frankfurt das finde ich
schon also es tut mir leid und wir haben
völlig recht auf diese ihren
rechtsextremen oder rechtsradikalen in
amerika hinzuweisen wir haben das
problem bei uns eben auch und das
problem ist es schaut sich die fratze
des antisemitismus von beiden seiten an
das ist unser problem und wir reden nur
über einem das ist wirklich nicht gut
ich muss jetzt einen harten beruf machen
den ich ehrlich gesagt ungerne mache ich
möchte mich auch irgendwie bei ihnen
bedanken ich finde es ganz wichtig das
thema heute abend mitgebracht haben
vielen dank